yes I have a question about god i want
to suggest that it may have all your
smorgasbord religious my deep apologies
only because I think there are
historical currents in particularly
religious traditions that give rise to
that kind of approach to the velocity
forms of Buddhism certainly forms of
canoes on where you can wander in a
street and Punjab India and walking to a
new household and feel depression or
next to a picture
and you ask what is this
contradiction it's a sort of orientation
to religion that allows one to collect
gems and those that do underlie a
particular worldview and I kind of I
like that in the United I want it I want
to argue that it doesn't
religions own self identity ya know I
think it's a good point and question
also is how does on the same we say
between synchronistic modes of
religiosity with relatively stable forms
of synchronistic modes of religiosity
which have been there in many places in
the world for very long periods of time
from relatively fast pace changing modes
of religiosity of picking and choosing
and crafting and kind of bricolage
religiosity as one goes goes along right
that's 11 distinction the other stage
III think you're in many ways in many
ways right that it can have certainly
positive values and certainly it reduces
tensions between religion and that's
that's a plus of smorgasbord religiosity
the possible minus might be depending
work from where you look is that the
generally they become a very much
individualistic and they do work for the
individual way I sometimes describe
various functions of religion so I don't
know whether I mentioned that I think I
mentioned in this class that they tend
to be that they tend to be then either
performance-enhancing drugs religions
you need to achieve something right and
then you didn't need spiritual energy to
do that right or they tend to be what I
call band-aid religions so you you kind
of walk through life you get bruised
here and there and then you need a bit
of bit of help or a kind of a local
wisdom for for action but they they
don't tend not to give you accounts of
of reality they tend not to form robust
enough communities in order to to resist
anything and to introduce social change
their kind of you float with them and
that may be what some people might like
and may be exactly what what's right but
from other perspective that maybe are
real detriment because you you can't
can create social movement for change
with these type of religiosity so it's
plus a nice so sorry if I was to may be
dismissive of him